foreign
[Music]
I'm
here today to deliver the newest
information about the title
first please enjoy this new gameplay
footage
how far can you've gone
[Applause]
anyone home
[Music]
hey
I read you
what's your situation
the hell is going on
what was that
no [ __ ] way
foreign
Huntington here what's your sit rep
president's daughter
's daughter our intel was correct then
well done
Something's Happened to people here
my escorts are
foreign
government
kill me for the repairs later
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
another place
[Music]
[Music]
what did you think
as you just saw
we are paying respect to the original
games World while implementing new ideas
and stated they are Graphics to
strengthen the Core Concepts of the
title
we think this game will provide a fresh
experience with the sense of familiarity
if you play the original that both
newcomers and Veterans to Resident Evil
4 will enjoy
saganados will have all new ways to
attack they are closing in on Leon
during his mission and will attack with
an even greater variety of methods than
in the original release Leon fights back
with Firearms close combat Maneuvers a
newly added Perry using his ninth and
more
foreign
[Applause]
resource management and upgrade elements
are critical for survival
just as in the original use using the
attache case effectively will be key in
addition to managing the weapons and
items you carry and synthesizing herbs
this also allows you to craft down
munition and other items
stranger of course we can't forget the
merchant
you can purchase weapons and items and
customize them to suit your play style
we've also added a trade mechanic where
rare gems you've collected can be
exchanged for special items you can't go
wrong with that
we are rebuilding the original game
while respecting its core experience
adding new ideas and modernizing the
play field
[Music]
now I'd like to share some new
information regarding this product's
release
we announced that Resident Evil 4 will
also be available on Playstation 4. in
addition to PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
and Xbox series s and PC
the PlayStation 4 version can be
upgraded to the PlayStation 5 digital
version at no additional cost
I'd like to introduce two other
additions we are preparing for players
looking for more than the standard
edition
is the deluxe edition which will be
available for all platforms
additional content such as costumes
special weapons a treasure map and more
next is the physical only collector's
edition
and contents of the deluxe edition as
well as a leon figure a special map
art book soundtrack and more
also pre-orders start today
if you pre-order the standard edition
you'll receive the attache case gold and
special charm handgun ammo
if you pre-order the deluxe edition or
collector's edition you'll receive the
standard edition pre-order bonuses as
well as attache case classic and special
charm green herb
if you pre-order the digital version on
the PlayStation Store you'll receive a
mini soundtrack
you can secure these bonuses by
pre-ordering Resident Evil 4.
thank you for watching so far we are
working hard to create a game that
everyone will enjoy
so please look forward to it